vamos a hacer esta revisión y veamos
cómo nos va tenemos 5.005 que lo
dividiremos en 37 vamos a ver cómo
funcionamos con esto tenemos ahora aquí
un decimal y vamos a aprender a manejar
estas divisiones van a ver que es mucho
muy sencillo la clave en estas
divisiones es mantener muy muy claro
dónde se encuentra el punto decimal en
este caso se encuentra a la derecha de
las unidades solo tenemos una unidad y
aquí se encuentra así es que subiremos
ese punto decimal y trabajaremos con
nuestra división como lo haríamos en
cualquier división larga usaremos el
mismo proceso
así que tendremos que cuántas veces
cabrá el 7 en el 5
0 y multiplicaremos 0 por 7-6
así que si le restamos a 50 tendremos 5
y aquí es donde les digo que mientras
tengamos claridad del lugar donde se
encuentra el punto decimal vamos a
seguir trabajando como si estuviéramos
con una división larga
tomaremos el siguiente número que en
este caso es este decimal tomaremos el
siguiente decimal y lo bajaremos ahora
tenemos 50
cuántas veces cabe 7 en 50 7 por 7 será
49 nos quedará perfecto 7 por 7 49 si a
50 le restamos 49 tendremos 1 como
recibo haremos exactamente lo mismo nos
moveremos hacia el siguiente decimal y
lo bajaremos hacia nuestro residuo
tendremos entonces 10
cuántas veces cabe el 7 en el 10
nos cabe una sola vez 7 por 1 es igual a
7 y si a 10 le restó 7 me quedarán 3
este será nuestro nuevo residuo
finalmente nos vamos con este 5
bajaremos el siguiente decimal y ahora
tendremos 35 para dividir entre 7
cuántas veces cabe 7 en 35 es esta
facilísima porque son 5 7 por 5 es igual
a 35 y si a 35 le restó 35 tendremos
tendremos un residuo de 0 y con eso
acabamos nuestra operación indica
entonces que 5.000 5
entre 7 será igual a 0.7 15